the big difference when he grows up in
fact we wanted to wait for the year 2001
he said he will have in his own house
not a computer as big as this but at
least a console to which you can talk to
his friendly local computer and get all
the information he needs for his
everyday life like his bank statements
his theater reservations holy
information you need in the course of
living in a complex modern society this
will be in a compact form in his own
house if our whole life is built around
the computer we become a
computer-dependent society and a
computer individuals in some ways but
they're also enrich our society because
any businessman and executive could live
comes anywhere on Earth and still do his
business through a device like this and
this is a wonderful thing it means we
wanted to be stuck in cities you better
live out in the country or wherever it
is and still carry on the complete
interaction with human beings as well as
with other computers
[Music]